how do you find investors and partners
for your business if you're running our
business you can't do everything
yourself it's not possible
successful entrepreneurs do not do
everything themselves you're always
going to be limited by how much time you
have and you don't have the skillset the
experience or probably the desire to do
everything right you're really good at
one thing or two things but you're not
good at the hundred things that you need
to make your business successful and so
a great option is to look at bringing on
people bringing on a team either in the
form of employees but also partners to
help you make this business successful
finding a partner is like getting
married though it is topic is something
that you need to really invest a lot of
time with because you don't want to give
up a part of your business to somebody
who's not going to be a long-term fit
for your company I got a great question
from one of my readers Andy who wrote in
a long email he's an inventor he's
created this adventure in weightlifting
category so he's helping people could be
life saving invention for weight lifters
he's 52 years old he wants to retire
he's got this great invention
and he's looking for investors and
partners to help him take this thing to
the next level but he doesn't know where
to start there's nowhere to find these
people if you want to find somebody who
was a potential partner for you the best
thing you can do is start hanging around
in the circles that you are already
passionate about so if the product is
about weight lifting I don't know why
you started this business I'm assuming
your weight lifter right I hope your
weight lifter hope you know something
about this business I'm assuming you're
a passionate weight lifter you need to
start hanging around people who are also
passionate about weight lifter you can
hang around with at the gyms with gym
owners you can hang around with people
online who are in forms and communities
you can hang around if there's events
community events if there's trade shows
if there's conferences that's where you
need to be you need to be hanging around
people who care about weightlifting
because your goal here is to find people
who you can connect with who have the
same value system as you who believe in
the same things as you do who love the
idea of building a business but who have
complementary skills to what you do
you're the inventor
so you need to find somebody who's great
at sales and marketing we have a greater
production great at creating
distribution deals and those people
exist there are people who are great at
marketing who love weightlifting and who
share the same value system as you do
who want the same thing as a vision for
the business as you do and that's going
to come by hanging around in those
circles you're not going to have a lot
of success going posting online hey I
need a partner for this business right
that's not how you go out and find the
business partner it's got to be somebody
who is passionate about your community
just as much as you do you are believes
in the same thing that you do and define
those guys where are they going to hang
out you want to hang out where they're
hanging out and that's going to be at
the gyms and the trade shows and the
conferences and you don't have to be the
big schmoozer networking guy you know
hanging out you hanging out your cars
everybody doesn't have to be you but you
should start to get known a little bit
in your community for this great
invention that you have among the early
adopters right the people who love
trying new things and spread the word
that you're looking for a partner spread
the word that you are looking for some
marketing help and some investment help
that's how you're going to find those
initial first people to partner up with
or potential employees or potential
investors to your business here's an
example to kind of bring that home a
little bit more I this new guy on my
team okay his name is Jason he's been
helping me a lot with my branding and
web design and strategy a great new
person on the team and I met him because
I did an event for this coffee shop here
in Toronto what happened was a bus ran
into the coffee shop it something
happened it was trying to swerve away
from a bicyclist and the bus ran right
into a coffee shop smashed through the
front door the business had to go out of
business for a while to close down and
repair the shop and I knew the owner
I loved her coffee and her drinks and I
thought wow imagine how bad that is
imagine how bad it is to have a business
you're already struggling enough it's
hard enough to run a bit
this you have to worry about a bus
coming through your front door and
having to shut down for a couple weeks
and so I thought you know what I'm going
to surprise this business owner and I'm
going to send out a newsletter to my
list and say hey everybody let's meet at
this store on this date at this time
we'll have fun get to know each other
and and buy some coffee and some treats
and support this entrepreneur that's
something that's core to me that's
something that I believe in I believe in
helping entrepreneurs helping the little
guy and being a part of entrepreneurial
success that's what I love doing Jason
was a guy who came out to that event so
right away here is a guy who believes
the same thing as I do
he believes in entrepreneurs he wants to
help this person out there's something
about him that he shares that value with
me that would make us potentially
compatible people who got that email
might say as a stupid I'm not going to
go to this I got something else that day
I'm not going to make it a priority
that's great I don't want to talk to
those guys they're not going to be
potential fits for me I want someone
who's just as excited about this idea as
I am and that's what you need to find
for your business so Jason came out to
this event and we met we had coffee it
was great we met a couple times
afterwards we developed the relationship
we never thought about hey we should
work together it wasn't my intention
going in but we ended up working on some
projects and then he came on board and
became a bigger part of my team the same
thing can happen for you you've got to
go to events that you feel passionate
about and get involved in the
weightlifting community and people will
gravitate towards you the same people
who have the same value system and
believe in what you're doing they'll
come to you and you can decide who might
be a good potential partner and what
help you need to grow this thing up but
you're not going to find the partner by
just emailing people or by searching on
the web that's not how you do it you've
got to make real personal connections
with people who share the same system as
you same ideals and hopefully be able to
build a long-term relationship with them
it's a little bit what it's a little bit
scary it's a little bit not so concrete
and it may not work the first time you
know you can't go to one event and
expect something great to happen but if
you keep going eventually you'll find
the right people to help you take your
business to where it needs to go you
have to believe that it's going to work
at believe those are you watching liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below and I'd love to hear what you have
to think leave a comment underneath let
me know your thoughts you have a
question leave it below make a video
response thank you so much and I'll see
you soon